ruler is an evidence-based approach for
integrating social and emotional
learning into schools ruler is an
acronym that stands for recognizing
understanding labeling expressing and
regulating emotions helping toddlers
regulate emotions using ruler building
warm and trusting relationships with
young children is foundational to
creating an emotionally safe environment
in early childhood classrooms ruler
helps teachers create an emotionally
safe environment by providing a
framework for modeling and teaching
emotional intelligence in the following
scenario watch how a teacher uses ruler
to help a child to regulate her emotions
when she feels nervous about new people
visiting the classroom as you watch look
for evidence of ways the teacher is
supporting Ella's ability to recognize
understand label express and regulate
her emotions
how many are you l/e our skills were you
able to identify in that clip if you
would like to learn more keep watching
as you saw ella was feeling nervous
about the new faces visiting her
classroom watch how the teacher
recognizes and labels Ella's feelings
the teacher then helps Ella understand
the causes of her feelings as she
describes to her what is happening in
the classroom next the teacher lets
Ellen know that the way she is
expressing her feelings is okay finally
the teacher uses a number of different
regulation strategies to help Ella feel
less nervous and to feel more
comfortable having visitors in the
classroom notice how she redirects
Ella's attention to her classmates uses
a calm tone of voice and holds and rocks
her as she sings
the language and modeling teachers use
with infants and toddlers lays a
foundation for children to recognize
emotions in themselves and others
understand the causes of their emotions
and develop vocabulary to label their
emotions ultimately helping children
feel safe expressing their emotions as
they learn strategies to regulate them
throughout the day you've seen how this
teacher used ruler to support Ella when
she was feeling nervous
to solidify your learning try to come up
with your own ideas for other ways ruler
could be used to help Ella regulate her
emotions and think about how you can use
ruler to support the children in your
own classroom